قد تبدو مدينة تشيستر الصغيرة في شمال إنجلترا
مكانًا غير محتمل للعثور على بعض
الحيوانات الأكثر عرضة للانقراض في العالم
[موسيقى]
ولكن منذ ثلاثينيات القرن العشرين، اكتسبت حديقة حيوان تشيستر
سمعة طيبة باعتبارها واحدة من أفضل الحدائق في
العالم من حيث الحفاظ على البيئة بهدف
مستهدف يتمثل في  منع انقراض الأنواع،
هناك
أزمة كبيرة في التنوع البيولوجي في الوقت الحالي،
أعني فقدان الأنواع بمعدل هائل
وبعض هذه الأنواع لن تكون على دراية
بها، ولا نعرف
نوع دورها، لذا يمكنك معرفة ذلك من خلال
إخراج الأنواع هنا الآن  لا نعرف
التأثير طويل المدى على هذا البئر.
المعيار الذهبي لحديقة حيوان تشيستر
هو تربية الأنواع لإعادة تقديمها إلى
بيئتها الطبيعية في كثير من الحالات. الآن ينصب
التركيز العاجل على إنشاء
شبكة أمان في الأسر
تقريبًا في حديقة الحيوان.  كقوس،
وقد نكون في موقف حيث
اختفى موطن الأنواع فعليًا،
فلن يعودوا إلى
بيئاتهم الطبيعية، وكان علينا أن ننظر نوعًا ما
إلى أماكن أخرى أخرى يمكننا
إعادتهم إلى التوازن، كما تعلمون أي شيء  نوع
من التأثير الذي تعلم أنه قد يكون
لحسن الحظ للحفاظ على بعض
هذه الأنواع المهددة بالانقراض،
حديقة الحيوان في خضم طفرة في المواليد لأندر
شمبانزي في العالم
[موسيقى]
ثلاثة توائم لحفرة مدغشقر وحيد القرن
الأكبر ذو القرن الواحد
[  موسيقى]
مستدق الملايو
وأخيرًا بالإضافة إلى
عائلة الجرابيات
الصباحية في حديقة الحيوان، زادت كيتاوا. أدى التعدين وإزالة
الغابات في بابوا غينيا الجديدة إلى انخفاض
عدد
الحيوانات البرية لشجرة الكنغر Goodfellows إلى أكثر من النصف على مدار
الثلاثين عامًا الماضية، لذا فإن ولادة جوي جديدة
في  توفر تشيستر بصيصًا من الأمل
لمستقبل هذه الأنواع،
لذا في المرة الأولى التي رأيناها كانت
صغيرة جدًا، كما تعلم نوعًا ما
أكبر قليلاً من جيلي بين وهي
متخلفة جدًا، أعني بصراحة أنك
لن تدرك ذلك حتى  كانت شجرة
كنغر ولكن بعد ذلك شهرًا بعد
شهر بعد شهر، يمكنك حقًا رسم
تلك العيون النامية التي تظهر ثم
فجأة تبدو في الواقع مثل
شجرة الكنغر. يُعزى
الكثير من نجاح تشيستر في التكاثر الآن
إلى مختبر الغدد الصماء الموجود في الموقع والذي
أشرف عليه.  فريق علم وظائف الأعضاء
والتكاثر ومختبر الغدد الصماء للحياة البرية لدينا
وهو الوحيد
من نوعه في حديقة حيوان في أوروبا، وهذا
يعني في الغالب أننا نقوم بقياس الهرمونات في
الحيوانات، لذلك بالنسبة لشيء مثل
شجرة الكنغر، سنأخذ عينات كل
يوم ثم سنقوم بذلك  قم بتشغيلها مرة واحدة تقريبًا في
الشهر حتى نتمكن من قياس
الهرمونات التناسلية لدى الأنثى، فهذا
يساعدنا على ربط الإشارات البصرية والسلوكيات
التي يراها الفريق مع
فسيولوجيا الحيوان وما
يحدث في الداخل حتى نتمكن من
التأكد من أننا نضع  الذكور والإناث
معًا في أفضل
وقت ممكن لمنحنا أفضل فرص
التكاثر الناجح. يحقق المختبر
نتائج مبهرة لدرجة أن حدائق الحيوان في جميع أنحاء
أوروبا ترسل عينات روث من
حيواناتها لتحليلها في تشيستر،
وهناك أمل في أن
يتمكن التركيز على الحفاظ على تشيستر من ذلك  إن كوننا نموذجًا لحدائق
الحيوان الأخرى لتتبع علمائنا هو
مجرد نموذج جديد لما يمكن أن تبدو عليه حديقة الحيوان المستقبلية،
كما تعلم أننا
ندمج كل هذه الجوانب نوعًا ما، كما
تعلم نوع الحفظ المباشر
للعمل ونماذج جمع التبرعات والصحة
في الواقع  ورفاهية
الزائرين الذين يزورون، لذا من
المؤكد أنك تعلم أن حديقة حيوان تشيستر
كانت ناجحة جدًا في ما تفعله ونحن
نشارك كل هذه المعلومات وشخصًا
تعرفه أيضًا يستخدم للقيام بنفس الشيء
الأجنبي